now
higher
further
faster
higher
further
faster show them what we
got I am sitting here with the director
of the Marvels Nia
how are you doing first of all are you
excited to see this thing out in the
world I'm so excited to see it out in
the world I'm doing well I'm really I'm
really proud of the work that um
everyone did especially looking at this
poster with these three women who are
just so amazing it's it's really
exciting to finally let it go when you
think about all that went into this film
creatively why should fans experience
this film in IMAX oh because it's huge
it's really big and and as someone who'd
been such a fan of IMAX from when I was
a kid um it was really great to create
sequences for IMX especially the
sequences that take place in space or
the really Dynamic sort of big sequences
dealing with like you know all these
amazing locations and characters it
really is um a large format visual
experience and you really feel that too
like I I definitely felt super immerse
in it and speaking of that you know our
exclusive expanded aspect ratio
something you touched on how did you
approach making those scenes open up
yeah was that like a conversation and
pre-production like I'm just curious to
see your process in that yeah um
basically the way I shoot also is I
really want it to feel the world to feel
big and I really you know I love space I
love space films and some of the first
some of the footage that we use as
reference for the movie was like IMAX
NASA footage um because we wanted to
feel real and grounded because space is
all inspiring on its own without adding
all these you know bells and muscles and
so we were really inspired by like like
uh documentary IMX footage um and so
that helped us to figure out what we
were going to do uh for the movie movie
and then also just you have a lot of
latitude when you're in IMX so you get
to show more so we got to create more
whether it was like um an alien world or
it was you know like a beautiful closeup
you know we really got to immerse
ourselves more and so that something
we've been thinking about from the
beginning that's so cool that you said
that you looked at like IMAX
documentaries I've been deep in like
editing space station 3D and Dreams live
and some of these like OG docs and so I
actually getting to go from editing
those to seeing like your film and the
way that you approach space like it
actually makes complete sense so cool
it's so cool so one question that we
like to ask like our filmmaker friends
um this is a theoretical question more
about you if you could experience any
film in IMAX again or for the first time
what would it be and why oh my gosh
that's a really hard
question
um you know what I thought was amazing
in IMAX this is just the first thing I
can think of uh the first dune didn't is
just so masterful and they I thought the
movie was was fantastic and I can't wait
to see the second one Dune was like such
a great experience in IMX yeah and the
noise and the sound just like vibrating
it was great you know this is your third
feature film and one thing that I think
is really interesting as a writer and
director is you know you're approaching
some characters that are an established
franchise and you know this is the SEC
the second time you've done that right
um yes yeah and so um I'm curious how do
you approach telling original stories
with established franchise
cornerstones I think it's finding where
I can be original so for this one like
the story that they want to tell felt
really daring and interesting um but it
was pretty much set with what Marvel
wanted to do but
um for me like bringing in like this
emotional underpinning with with the con
family and with their the three of their
relationship was like really really
exciting and that was sort of where I
was like okay this is where I can put my
stamp on the film this is where I mean
obviously I'm directing it so it's
everywhere but just in terms of like
what feels new and exciting about this I
think it's this relationship the
switching um and also having this this
Con Family actually at the center of
like the film's beating heart which I
feel like those were some of the best
moments like where I'm just like that
you can tell the chemistry there for
sure it's it's amazing and so I was so
happy to inherit them as a director I'm
just curious because you know I've done
a lot of research on you and your
background and the directors that you've
gotten to work with if you could
theoretically pick the brain of any
director living or or gone now who would
you pick and why just to like pick their
R ooh oh my goodness that's a tough
question
um I was talking about Sydney LT earlier
today so probably him yeah yeah I mean
he's written a book so you kind of have
a little insight but he'd be he'd be
amazing that'd be incredible well I'm
happy I got to pick your brain thank you
so much for sitting down me I love
this